[Music]
what do you say to the people you meet
who are on the third marriage their kids
don't talk to them and there are certain
things that they have convinced
themselves subconsciously or otherwise
maybe through an abusive upbringing or
trauma whatever it might be that it is
unsafe to feel certain things and you
come in they've asked for help but they
do not want to open Pandora's box right
they do not want someone to drag them
into the deep waters of emotions that
they've kept under lock and key for so
long how do you help someone like that
what do you suggest to them because it
does get messy it's gonna get messy
before it gets clean this in my
experience it's like you oh you're gonna
do spring cleaning guess what you gotta
take all the things are up on the up on
the shelves all the things in the
drawers all the things that are hanging
on coat hangers and you're gonna put
them in the middle of the room and it's
gonna be out mess it's gonna be a
[ __ ] mess you're gonna be pissed that
you did it and that is it and that is
but you can't really get past go without
that type of step so for someone who's
listening to this and says you know what
I buy it like I get it and yet what do I
do
because I've been I've had on this armor
for so long so I would say a couple of
things and the first thing I always feel
like is really important to say is that
I'm a researcher and so I'm not a
therapist that would be differentiate me
when Esther like I don't see clients if
I go in and I'm working with CEOs and
this question comes up all the time
what I would say to people is Pandora's
Box is closed right now but are you
under the impression they were living
outside of the box or in the box like
you know I like that yeah I mean like
you don't want to open Pandora's box
because that's strange to me because
you're living inside Pandora's box and
what I feel like you've asked me to come
here to open it up like we're not gonna
do this process without walking through
some deep [ __ ] where there's going to be
deep Swift water and if the water is
super deep and Swift you need to go
through that with a therapist and get
that that settle before we work in the
organizational way but what I would say
people what I always say is is the same
for me and I'm sure the same for you
that we all grew up and experienced it
very varying degrees trauma
disappointment how you know hard stuff
we armored up and at some point that
armor no longer serves us and so what I
think I would say to that person is how
is not talking about this serving you
mm-hmm
like I've been sober for 23 years so
someone in a would be like how's that
[ __ ] working for you hmm you know like
but I probably would put a softer spin
on it than that no for black coffee a
cigarette but you know but I would say
that it's not serving anymore
and now the weight of the armor is too
heavy and it's not protecting you it's
keeping you from being seen and known by
others and so this is I mean just tell
you Quinn essentially this is the
developmental milestone of midlife from
late 30s to you know through probably
your 60s this is the question hmm yeah
this is when the universe comes down and
puts their hands on your shoulders and
pulls you close and whispers in your ear
I'm not [ __ ] around you're halfway to
dead hmm the armor is keeping you from
growing into the gifts I've given you
that is not without penalty time is up
hmm so this is what you see happen to
people in midlife and it's not a crisis
it's a slow brutal unraveling and this
is where everything that we thought
protected us keeps us from being the
partners the parents the professionals
the people that we want to be and there
are only I've only seen this is a fork
in the road I've only seen two responses
to this visit from the universe well
there's I guess there's there was my
response which I was like screw you
bring it like you think you can do you
think you can best me and then it was
just one nightmare
situation after another until yeah
you're not gonna win that fight right I
think if you say you know what I'm not
I'm not gonna do it then you've got to
double down these are the people that
walk through the world double down on
their own [ __ ] in denial you know cheek
squeezed as they walk and cause so much
pain in the world
yeah to themselves as well I mean yes
because it is so much easier to offload
pain than to feel pain yeah and so you
really have a choice in midlife whether
you're going to be you're gonna you know
identify into the first step of it the
whole process is what Armour and I'm not
saying like I'm not saying just pull off
all the armor and streaked through
Austin because I think you can't replace
the armor with something
I think it's curiosity is what you
replace that you just become very
curious about yourself about the world
why did I react that way when Tim asked
me that question I wanted to like hit
him over the head with a topo cheaper
model you know what was going on there
jeanna mean like what is my obsession
about this you just become very curious
is curiosity is really the superpower
for the second half of our lives because
it keeps us learning it keeps us asking
questions and it increases our
self-awareness but when you see and I
think it's really hard because you know
I'll walk into situation and they'll be
the person who invited me is usually the
CEO and then you'll have like the
cross-armed pissed off clenched cheek
like if you look in person usually in
operations or technology you know and
then they're like what's the business
case for you being here you know right
like because you know here's our stock
price here's what's going on here's our
valuation like why what it what do you
need and then you know the CEO usually
say [ __ ] hate each other and this can
only last for so long like you know it's
the end of every great band right like
this is gonna come to an end and it's
gonna be terrible and so I don't know I
think you can't pull it all off at once
you have to there's a lot of people for
all of us there's trauma yeah
and people are like no there's not
trauma for all of us there's trauma for
you know people who had been abused
physically sexually emotionally there's
trauma for people of color and people
who have been on the margins there's
trauma for all of us it's just different
levels of trauma yeah you know I mean
dig escape childhood with nothing is I
haven't met that person yet no I haven't
either
right so the trauma staff literally the
trauma message in our body is you take
this armor off we die so you protect us
at all cost
and leave us on a lot of that work has
to be done with a therapist
you